this is kind of a new moment in your
life your single new sitcom what does
this moment mean for Anna camp well
great question um you know what I
finally I feel like kind of free for the
first time in a very long time for lots
of reasons my birthday is coming up in a
couple of weeks also it just feels
exciting I feel like you're excited and
also very grounded at the same time
which is great and I haven't felt this
way in like a while so it's a new it's a
new thing for me which I'm you know
excited about anything for you but it
seems like you like found yourself
through all this I'm a journey it's a
long journey but I definitely feel like
I have taken some steps to really that
you know that are scary at times and I
feel like I'm more I'm stronger than I
thought that I was which is also very
empowering for me and that is
translating also into my work and the
jobs that I'm taking and also into my
personal life so yeah it feels pretty
good part of this new moment for Anna is
her new show perfect harmony on NBC you
slouch it's caused by a fear of
confrontation which is why you stayed
married to a man who ate a snake loose
in the house did you read my diary
I wrote it it kind of felt like all of
the chips fell into place for me it felt
like all of my jobs that I have had kind
of led me to this job which has been I'm
a I am from the south I love playing
southern women and I love singing and I
love dancing and I love comedy so I
really kind of all clicked into place so
I just felt like everything's gonna bled
me to this moment I feel like this show
is just ripe for a pitch-perfect reunion
we gotta get some of those girls in one
of those church robes I would love it I
would love it always I love working with
them I would die to have any of them all
of them on the show at some point it
would be a dream what song would you
pull out for a little patriot reunion
duet
oh my gosh oh well you know what I would
love to sing like a little worse than
loose in Kentucky so I would love to
sing like a Kacey Musgraves song
um something would be really fun blowin
smoke I love that's one of my favorite
song she's got a bunch of them like a
bunch of heads yeah she's great I'd like
to hear the church you take on that
golden hour she's singing about like the
guy that she's never mind we just talked
about the Kacey Musgraves discography on
that all your cast members have given us
a little bit of the et theme on the way
down the line so can you give me a
little EG theme
[Music]